all right when I first saw a trailer to
RIPD I thought to myself this is men in
black meets Constantine but now I
retract that night admit I was wrong
it's not actually like that it's men in
black meets Jonah Hex a bit RIPD that
stands for rest in peace department
all right Petey is the story of this cop
played by Ryan Reynolds he gets killed
in action in heaven or the afterlife or
whatever it's like we want you to join
the rest in peace department which is
their souls on earth you should be going
to judgment but they're not they don't
want to do so they stay on earth and
they haunt the place and then the MIB d
need to go down there and round them up
and bring them back for judgement and of
course in true rip-off fashion the new
rookie to this whole supernatural thing
needs to get paired up to this veteran
older dude in this case it's Jeff
Bridges and now they go about their
adventures and I know it's going to be a
really cliche thing for people who are
reviewing this movie to compare it to
men in black but you just can't help it
it's that familiar only difference is
men and black did it a lot better now
that you know I thoroughly feel that
this movie is ripping off men in black
let's judge it as a movie as a movie
it's just it's really not good first of
all we'll talk about the chemistry
between Ryan Reynolds and Jeff Bridges
it's not there so I can't really talk
about it because it's not they're
talking about the chemistry between Ryan
Reynolds and Jeff Bridges so be like
talking about the scene and Empire
Strikes Back when Han Solo took the
lightsaber and cut Princess Leia in half
it doesn't exist so I can't talk about
that same same goes for the chemistry
between these two guys I like these two
guys these two guys are good actors Jeff
Bridges is clearly the better but I like
Ryan Reynolds a lot the dudes funny the
dude has talent too dude has good timing
I'm just saying these two don't work
well together that might not even be on
them the scripts not particularly good
it doesn't unlock them a lot to work
with it's cliche stale [ __ ] Jeff
Bridges for a while all right
at a point in the movie Jeff Bridges the
furniture of our lives where you're
gonna stay where they were strange if I
miss another time he's gotta just
Bridget sucks like a rose like this
newcomer man and now Jeff Bridges talks
like that in a lot of [ __ ] unless it's
Tron Legacy and you don't really buy the
movie I'm down for having a movie that's
pretty much men and black for the
supernatural but one you're not even
buying the monsters because the monsters
don't look real it's it's [ __ ] CGI you
look at the CGI in this movie you're
like not bad for 15 years ago but here
we are 2013 avatar has happened I don't
require avatar CGI and everything but no
we got CGI that looks no more impressive
than Dexter's diner from attack of the
clones and these shitty looking monsters
are being hunted down by a couple of
guys who have absolutely no chemistry in
this movie just RIPD was it was just
cheap and lazy and the movies really
predictable you know exactly how the
movie's gonna go down Kevin Bacon's in
the movie know exactly what role he's
gonna play I mean Kevin Bacon in a movie
like this you know he's gonna be a
scumbags like having Brad Dourif
in a movie you're like he's gonna he's
bad news he's not playing Santa Claus
anytime soon it all happens exactly how
you know it's gonna happen never being a
secret organization nothing's really
hidden there's this one segment Jeff
Bridges is bouncing off of buildings and
people are seeing this happen they're
like holy [ __ ] this is happening
monsters are running everywhere it's
just chaos and I get it they're trying
to have the apocalypse happen so extreme
things are going to happen in this
situation but the movie gives you the
impression that these really sketchy
monsters can just go rage out and run
through a crowd of people at any time
and no one has ever seen this happen
before even saying the movie like this
has never happened before ever like it's
never happened I guess it's never
happened and I just don't buy that at
least men in black had the flashy thing
that's all boom alright this is what
happened you're at a ball game with your
girlfriend and she threw soda in your
face that's not Slimers slime from
ghostbusters I swear this has nothing
like that [ __ ] happens and now everyone
knows and I think that through I like
the two main actors in this movie but
RIPD was lazy it's just a cheap move is
a movie that was easy to do so like yeah
I get it men in black landed on that
Plymouth Rock but let's just do a worst
version of it why not it just makes
total sense there's a part of me that
wants to say it's alright but you're not
gonna remember it in t-minus one day but
I know months down the road I'm gonna
look back on RIPD and be like why didn't
I just call it what it was why didn't I
just call it dog [ __ ] because RIPD is
lazy dog [ __ ] all right Petey's the kind
of movie that should have come out in
January or February summer movie no idea
they gave us [ __ ] knowing it [ __ ] and
for that I give them dog [ __ ] so RIPD
have you seen it what did you think
about it here you see how many other
people find it you know completely
[ __ ] terrible or at least a men in
black ripoff whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
angel illusion trunks Windom you don't
drop eyelid master control program when
we haven't